[Musique]
après avoir arpenté les planches pendant
des années avec le théâtre vollard
aujourd'hui pierre louis rivière écrit à
plein temps il a accepté de se confier à
non ici au musée de villèle
[Musique]
merci pierre rivière de nous accorder un
peu de votre temps
je sais que les lieux sont importants
pour vous qu'est-ce que vous évoque le
musée de villèle ou là le musée de
villèle pour moi c'est surtout un lieu
où j'ai travaillé il ça brasse beaucoup
de choses de notre histoire c'est un
lieu que je fréquente beaucoup mois
dernier roman verte' vous là aussi les
lieux sont importants va dans les eaux
de linde qu'est ce que vous vouliez
raconté il ya le personnage narrateur
qui qui est arpenteurs comme on dit
maintenant géomètre la position de
géomètre est très importante surtout à
la réunion parce que le géomètre
parcours tout le territoire et il est au
courant de toutes les histoires qu'ils
soient qu'ils se racontent ou qui ceux
qui sont réelles sur les familles les
héritages les disputes et c'est donc
c'est un lieu privilégié
je fais le tour de la construction
inhabitée depuis des années je sens son
regard aveugle suivre chacun de mes pas
lorsque je redescends l'aller le regard
aveugle de la maison pèsent encore sur
ma nuque
après il ya une autre histoire qui se
greffent dans cette histoire puisque
quand ils se retrouvent dans cette
maison il est confronté a entre
guillemets des fantômes c'est à dire
qu'ils trouvent quelques traces du passé
et qui se met à essayer d'enquêté qu'est
ce que c'est qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi etc
c'est des histoires qui traînent dans
toutes les familles créoles qui sont pas
dit on cache on n'en parle pas des
secrets de famille et ce roman s'appelle
vertige
est ce que c'est pour provoquer ce
sentiment de vertige le lecteur ou alors
c'est le personnage lui-même qui est
dans une situation de vertige je me suis
arrêté sur vertige parce que dans le
roman il ya une ya eu neuf une figure de
style ou
je sais pas un motif qui revient c'est
le motif de la spirale donc ce vertige
laïque il est le vertige de ces
histoires l'histoire ancienne qu'il
essaye de reconstituer aussi est un peu
vertigineuse parce qu'ils sont pris dans
un tourbillon qui n'arrive pas à
maîtriser
et puis il ya une lectrice qui m'a dit
un métier me vertige parce que à cause
d'une d'hitchcock
oui dans vertigo il ya un personnage
comme ça on sait pas s'il est réel ou ou
si c'est une reconstitution donc là ça
me correspondait bien à l'histoire donc
j'ai gardé verte et finalement ça
correspond parfaitement et c'est un
livre qui plaît est-ce que les romands
quand vous écrivez comment les idées
viennent alors ça c'est la grande
question je travaille je prends des
notes j'écris des bribes je lis beaucoup
et c mais après j'ai besoin de partir
j'ai besoin de mes m'isoler complètement
j'ai besoin de confinement volontaire
pas obligatoire
et pour ce roman j'ai été sept mois à
lisbonne j'ai besoin d'être dans un pays
où ce que les personnes ou très peu de
gens je ne parle pas la langue je la
prends et je ne suis sollicité par
personne je suis quand même assez
d'istres et moi on est samedi matin
peut-être le temps s'étire et se ramasse
en d'étranges mouvements
tu es assis sur le petit fauteuil du
salon
tu te penches sur les documents que tu
as glanés au cours de la semaine
tes pensées sont absorbés par une
histoire qui t'échappe vous avez aussi
transmettre
qu'est ce qui est important de passer à
la nouvelle génération un milliard de
choses que j'aimerais transmettre mais
il ya une chose importante quand on
donne dans une île une île créole ou
dans une île dans un dans une culture
qui est un peu fermé moi j'ai toujours
vu la mer comme des murs ici on n'est
pas comme aux antilles où on prend une
petite barque on va à sainte lucie la
mer nous nous nous enferme un peu
donc c'est important d'aller ailleurs
donc moi j'incite les étudiants par
exemple à partir quand c'est possible
après ils reviennent sur leur propre
culture créole et ils ont un autre
regard complètement différent comme quoi
il faut
ouvrir et s'enrichir merci beaucoup les
rivières
merci le thorium